[Music]
so for about a year
we've been talking about the
presidential election out there
somewhere on the horizon you wake up
this morning and you realize
it's 47 days away
less than a month from right now we will
be the first tuesday
in november and we're going to vote for
a new president
this has been by far the most intense
presidential election season
in the lifetime of anyone watching it
but it feels like we're moving
towards something even more intense
what's going to happen
on election day and in the days
following
the people who've been thinking most
clearly about this
on both sides are the people who've done
it before who've been
involved at a high level on a
presidential campaign steve bannon has
done that he's one of the people who
ran donald trump's 2016 effort he was
recently back in the news last month he
was indicted on fraud charges
related to a non-profit of build the
wall non-profit he was running he hasn't
been on television
since then he hasn't given any
interviews on advice of counsel
but we wanted to hear what he thinks is
going to happen
as we move toward november we also
wanted to ask him about the charges
against him he agreed to come on tonight
and we're happy to have him steve bannon
thanks a lot
for coming so i i want to ask you thank
you thanks for having me
you re-emerged in the national
consciousness in a fairly big way
in august when you were arrested on
fraud charges you haven't responded
uh publicly that i'm aware of to those
charges so i want to give you a chance
uh to sum up your views on it
well you know bill burks my attorney you
know him i think he's the best attorney
in in d.c so he says hey
you should lay off this but look i i got
to come forward
you know attorney general barr said i
think at hillsdale the other night
this is uh this is head hunting of high
profile
uh political targets that are associated
with president trump it's not random
that it was four years almost to the day
that i took over the campaign that these
this indictment came out right what
these guys wanted to do was
criminalize political speech make sure i
didn't go back to the campaign what they
messed up is i was never going back to
the campaign the campaign's in great
shape
you got bill stepping in jason miller
steve cortez others
they're doing a great job and will
deliver a victory on november 3rd for
president trump so
i have been because of my work on war
room pandemic we were the first guys to
be on the pandemic in january
we understood what your opening segment
was about tucker
the democratic party has traumatized
their base they're not going to come out
to vote
and so somehow they have to concoct a
some effort
to steal this election because they're
not going to get people to come out and
vote on game day
the third of november of this year and
that's what i've been working on for the
last couple of months i was never going
back i was never going back to the
campaign
and that's where these guys messed up my
platform's bigger now my voice is bigger
i've got more resources
and all we're focused on is to make sure
that the progressive
left and the corporatist it cannot steal
cannot steal the election with donald
trump
i i want to just drill down briefly
because this is a complex topic and
you're going to have an opportunity to
respond in court
um but the the sort of macro charge you
is you defrauded people who sent you
money to build a wall
you said you wouldn't take any money the
chargers claim that you did
what's your response to that i i had my
c4 had a one-man if you read the
indictment i had a one million dollar
contract
okay to kind of be the dc office oversee
the wall
uh construction to to do seminars
conferences if you want to see it
you know go to vice news go to bbc go to
the opening
season of showtimes the circus the
opening episode the 19th season
they're traveling around the country
following us on these town halls we had
town halls conferences
we built a wall of two-thirds of a mile
of wall up a mountain in el paso
within a hundred days of starting i was
i was a contractor and ran an advisory
board
that brought together the best and
brightest of all the wall people so
they're not going to criminalize they're
not going to shut me down about talking
about the wall they're not going to
criminalize us talking about the world
regarding kobach and sheriff clark and
all these guys so
that's what the indictment failed to say
but look all will come out in court
it will it will and i don't is that
they're not
yeah the key thing is they're not going
to show me they want to criminalize
political speech
and they're not going to shut me down
i'm more focused than
ever we're kicking off a national tour
on monday
called the plot to steal 2020. they're
not going to stop my voice
in assisting president trump and making
sure that this
election that he's going to win on the
third is not stolen from him
big tech is clearly taking a side in
this election
they have unprecedented levels of power
over what
people know and i'm wondering how you
think they will use that power as we
approach the election specifically
you you saw the other night you had
doctor young on from from uh from china
as a fact witness on the on the weapons
labs over there
and also wrote this amazing paper what
what
what twitter did is ripped her twitter
account down right away they took her
off facebook when they
had to replay your show that was on fire
throughout the world and but they
allowed the chinese communist party to
beat down on her
every second with all of their running
dogs that's what you're going to see
that's a preamble to what's going to
happen on november 3rd
they're talking about it they're already
saying both facebook and twitter
that they're not going to announce a
winner here's what's going to happen
donald j
trump is going to win the vote on the
only day that matters
that's november 3rd he's going to win
the real election
in the way we've done it with secret
ballots with people going into a booth
and voting for president united states
okay
by that evening he will be the winner
and what they're going to do is that
between the law fair they've got with
800 attorneys under eric holder
the mob they've got with antifa and the
radical elements of black lives matter
but most importantly the digital muscle
of facebook
and twitter they're going to sit there
and they're going to not declare trump
the winner
you were right there running the
campaign four years ago today
looking at the poll numbers now as
objectively as you can as compared to
the numbers you were looking at
four years ago today how do you think
the president's reelect looks
i think the president i think the team's
done a great job when i look at these
numbers in the in the cross tabs when i
drill down on them
i think the president's got a not just a
great shot i think he will be the winner
on november 3rd i think that
i think the campaign's totally focused i
think biden is a cipher
he can't draw a crowd so i think i think
right now
that i think the campaign's doing great
the president is doing great i see a
victory
on november third and i was a guy first
guy to tell him he was going to win back
in august of 16.
and then maybe the real contest begins
steve bannon i'm glad that you came on
thank you very much that's when the war
starts
all right thanks i'm beginning to think
that's true
um appreciate it thank you